بكين تقدم اقتراحا يقلل الخسائر
على اوكرانيا فهل يقبل به
وجائحة كوفيد ناينتين في لبنان.
دعا وزير الدفاع السوداني المكلف
الدولي على تمويل اضافي بقيمة
ثلاثمائة مليون دولار للمشروع
الصينية ماونينج ان بكين ستتخذ
التدابير اللازمة لمنع ووقف جميع
البنية التحتية الحيوية للصين.
واضافت المتحدثة باسم الخارجية
تقارير تفيد باطلاق الحكومة
الامريكية هجمات الكترونية على
المتحدة الامريكية. بينما قالت
وزارة الخارجية الصينية ان هناك
تتجه اوكرانيا الى خسارة اراضيها
تدريجيا امام القوات الروسية
عمله بزعم منها انها تنفذ عملية
امنية لضبط مطلوبين. قال جيش
يستهدفون المدنيين. كما منعت
قوات الاحتلال الهلال الاحمر من
المسلحة السودانية وكل القادرين
على حمل السلاح للتوجه الى
رويترز. ويأتي هذا الاجراء بسبب
الوضع المتوتر في كوسوفو حيث تم
الاستعداد القتالي وتقدمه نحو
كوسوفو وفقا لما اوردته وكالة
ثلاثة عشر فلسطينيا بالرصاص الذي
ينطلق من اسطح المنازل عبر قناصة
الكيان انه مسيرة اجتازت الحدود
الاسرائيلية من جهة لبنان. بينما
الطارئ لدعم شبكة الامان
الاجتماعي للاستجابة للازمة
النظر الى الصين باعتبار بديلا
تجاريا واقتصاديا عن الولايات
الخاص الصينية لشؤون اوراسيالي
هوي حتى الدول الاوروبية على
انتخاب البالي عمدة لبلدية شمال
ميتروفيتشا رغم مقاطعة الاغلبية
وهنا ننتقل الى ازمة عميقة
ومعقدة بين واشنطن وموسكو. حيث
صرامة وفق الخارجية الروسية.
لتتواصل هنا المعارك بين الروس
قوات من المواطنين دون تدريب.
وقالوا لهم سوف تعلمكم باخموت.
باخمود خلال معارك المدينة.
ووفقا للصحيفة حشد قادة كييب
ليؤكد وزير الدفاع الصربي رفع
جاهزية الجيش الى اقصى درجة من
الاوكرانية. حيث تكشف الصحف
الامريكية كل يوم عن قضية وازمة
اوكرانيا مع اقتراحه شرطا واحدا
وهو احتفاظ روسيا بالاراضي
الصربية للتصويت. دلع اشتباكات
واعمال عنف في شمال كوسوفو بين
اراضي روسيا بما في ذلك جمهورية
القرم ومنطقة بلقرود الروسيتان.
جديدة على نار هادئة. هناك امر
الرئيس الصربي الكسندر فوتشيتش
اوكرانيا رد متحدث الكرملين
ديمتري بسكو بقوله ان الرئيس
نيته الاتصال بالرئيس الروسي من
اجل التفاوض بشأن السلام في
بينما لا تزال الخطط المحددة
للعضوية في الناتو بعيدة المنال
ولكنه جبان حسب تعبيره. ومن
روسيا الى صربيا حيث تطبخ حرب
ميدفيديف ان نتائج الانتخابات
الامريكي لسنة الفين واربعة
ان اي شكل من اشكال العدوان ضد
روسيا سيلقى حتما ردود فعل اكثر
كان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي قد اظهر موافقته على
بقوات غير مدربة وتعاني من نقص
واضح في المعدات الى مفرمة لحم
جديدة. واليوم كشفت صحيفة بورسل
الجرنال الامريكية ان كييف دفعت
الفريق ركن ياسين ابراهيم ياسين
المتقاعدين من منتسبي القوات
وجرافتين لمداهمة مخيم عقبة في
مدينة اريحا. ما ادى الى اصابة
القيادة لتسليحهم. استخدم
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خمسين الية
انواع الهجمات الالكترونية التي
تهدد امن التحتية. وافق البنك
اكثر بين الغرب وموسكو وتسوق
الاحداث نحو مواجهة مباشرة. حيث
الدول الاوروبية والولايات
المتحدة على تزويد كييب باسلحة
ميدفيديف عاد ليوجه بوصلة حديثه
نحو اوروبا. بقوله ان القارة
الاحداث والتطورات. ذكرت صحيفة
بول ستريت جورنال ان الممثل
هؤلاء مما يجري في اوكرانيا
فالحرب لا تأتي الا بالاسوء.
افراد من القوات الخاصة في
كوسوفو والصرف. فلتتريث قليلا يا
والوجانس. فهل تقبل كييه لنعد
الى الحرب في الاراضي
بوتين منفتح لاي حوار يصب في
حماية مصالح البلاد مشيرا الى ان
الازمة الاوكرانية الى الوقف
الفوري للعمليات العسكرية في
الجديدة اي المقاطعة الاربع وهي
خرسون وزبروتشا والدونيتس
شولتس لم يتصل بعد. ومن جهته دعا
ليهوي المبعوث الصيني لتسوية
بوضع الجيش في حالة تأهب قصوى
والاقتراب من الحدود مع كوسوفو.
بعد تدريب الطيارين وهو ما
سيستغرق عدة اشهر اي ان ارسال
الحمراء. حيث افادت وكالة
بلومبرج نقلا عن مصادرها المطلعة
وعشرين ستكون مقبولة بالنسبة
لروسيا اذا لم تأتي بشخص مصاب
بالخرف رئيسا للولايات المتحدة.
مضيفا ان دونالد ترامب رجل طيب
والامريكان. حيث قال نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري
كبار دبلوماسيي السفارة
الامريكية لدى موسكو احتجاجا على
التصريحات غير المقبولة من
سوليفان. وحذرت موسكو واشنطن من
ليأتي الرد الروسي فورا. حيث
استدعت وزارة الخارجية روسية
شريك في الحلف وذلك دون المساس
بموضوع ضمها كعضو في الناتو
يعتزم حلف الناتو الاقتراح على
اوكرانيا رفع وضعها الى مستوى
نووية. ما الذي تقوله يا هذا؟
ومن ذا الذي يجرؤ على خطوة نووية
مبادرات السلام. وبعد تصريحات
المستشار الالماني اولفشولز حول
عن اوكرانيا وفق موقع يورو
اكتيف. ومن مسعرات الحرب الى
الضربات التي شنتها التشكيلات
المسلحة للنظام في كييف على
كهذه؟ لكن دعوني اقول لكم عن
خطوة واقعية اكثر قد تصعد التوتر
سمته بحدود عام واحد وتسعين. لكن
مهلا مهلا ما الذي باستطاعة ثمان
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين خلال
الاسابيع المقبلة تحت قيادة
واربعين طائرة ان تفعله امام
اسطول الدب الروسي المخيف.
الولايات المتحدة ذاتها. والبنك
الدولي يقدم هدية للبنانيين
والسودان يدعو كل من يقدر على
حمل السلاح. النهاية لا تقترب.
تندلع مع كوسوبو. الصين تحث دول
اوروبا على شريك تجاري اقوى من
استبشروا خيرا بموعد وصول
الطائرات لتكشف كييف انها بحاجة
الى ثمان واربعين مقاتلة امريكية
من طراز ستة عشر للعودة الى ما
برنامج تدريب من الدنمارك
وهولندا. من جانبهم الاوكراني
طائرات اف ستة عشر لاوكرانيا
سيكون منتصف العام المقبل بحسب
العجوز اصبحت مجنونة وتحاول
تأجيج الوضع ولم يستبعد ان تقدم
انه من المرجح ان ترسل هولندا
طائرات اف ستة عشر الى اوكرانيا
انه طالما ظل نظام الاوكراني
الحالي والمهرج الزالنسكي في
وكالة تاسا. وهنا تأتي هولندا من
بعيد لتتجاوز اشارة بوتين
يتمكن في المستقبل القريب من
تحقيق اهدافهما. ميدفيديف اضاف
القومي الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف
انه يتوقع ان يستمر الصراع
بوتين الاحمر بينما تعلن صربيا
عن حالة التأهب القصوى والحرب
بشرط واحد فما هو هذا الشرط؟
وهولندا تعلن موعد دوسها على خط
السلطة في كييف فان المحادثات
ستكون مستحيلة وفق تعبيره بحسب
بلومبرج ليشير وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن الى بدء
لعقود، بينما ترى واشنطن بدورها
ان الطرفين الاوكراني والروسي لن
مؤشر لنهاية قريبة للقتال.
ليعلنها نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
سيناريو الرصاصة الاخيرة غير
وارد في حرب اوكرانيا وما من
الاوكرانيون?
خطيرة بخصوص اوكرانيا فكيف سيرد
بوتين? والصين تقدم مقترح سلام
موسكو تعلنها. اوروبا جربت كل
شيء لدعم اوكرانيا وها هي تتحضر
للقتال دون تدريب? قائلة سوف
تعلمكم باخموت والنيتو يتخذ خطوة
لارسال نووي. هل جنون الاوروبيين
يا سادة? وكيف تحشد المواطنين